it's happening all right folks Chris
waters here live on gamespot stage with
Eric Osborne head of community at Bungie
weren't about to talk destiny so if you
want to send any questions my way I will
ask Eric to send them to @ct waters on
Twitter sea TWA tt-rs
Eric welcome to the stage hey thanks for
having me it's it's my pleasure destiny
you guys have been you guys are got some
stuff brewing
you guys are up showing up in press
conferences launching entire bundles
yeah we got our alpha live so the game
stood up you can play through a huge
swath of content so you create a
character choose a class play a story
chapter go out and explore the world
find some stuff out I find treasure find
loot find some friends so you're telling
me competitive multiplayer we got a
strike up in live it's all going live
Thursday out in the booth we've got our
crucible competitive multiplayer for
hands-on a lot of times when people are
describing alphas I feel like they were
to last like a third of as long as you
were just describing all the stuff I
could do with that alpha yeah we felt it
was super important to get a big chunk
of the game out and really were ramping
up to our beta our biggest gotten so big
that we wanted to make sure it was gonna
stand up to all the players are going to
hit it and we want to make sure that
people could really experience it we get
test out a lot of the new systems that
we're building and of course that pushes
us to launch on September 9th so it's
really critical that we get a lot of
data both um the backend services and
what players are doing in the world and
the design decisions that we've made
yeah you guys are pretty much going full
speed into from now it's gonna be pretty
break right next to it absolutely all
right so the Alpha folks can get into
this they're gonna they want to know how
let's just tell them how right now yeah
so you can go to a greatness awaits
dot-com slash destiny
okay register and you'll get an email
back assuming you're chosen
it'll be limited we're not saying how
many people are in the right just right
now we want to make sure we can scale up
appropriately in ramp sure but assuming
things go well we're expecting a pretty
large number of players to hit that
right and of course that's gonna lead to
our beta which will expand out from
PlayStation 4 to places in for
PlayStation 3 Xbox one and Xbox 360 all
together and that mate is coming in July
17th in July yeah guys are you guys are
really on it your schedule is crazy I do
it so here I can't let it go so here we
are in a competitive multiplayer match
yeah this mode the basic premise is just
you know control
the points yeah like Devils third the
object is to take the fruit into the
blender I didn't see the last second
that second make sense right no control
this is 66 you bring your guardian into
the mode we're watching a first light on
the moon you definitely want to control
the control points the control zones
because they'll give you modifiers to
your points so kill Beth is obviously
really important yeah but if you've got
all three zones locked down you're gonna
get a plus 200 bonus to your kills so
it's really important to make sure
you're monitoring the map keeping your
head on a swivel taking territories back
from players this is a see here
vehicular combat stay trauma staple for
our team we've got mics going
interceptors going you can actually
conjure your personal vehicle if you
want to take it for a spin on this this
match every character in here is rockin
their own loadout these are the weapons
they've chosen you can change them on
the fly in the middle of the match if
you want I learned this when I got to
play a match of this last week that not
all loadouts are created equal of course
not like we definitely want players to
invest in their character and find out
builds that work for them so on this map
I might go with a sniper rifle because
there's a little more sight line yeah oh
and an assault rifle to sort of back
myself up one date in the close quarters
but it's really about owning territories
map knowledge winning one-on-one fights
and communicating and playing as a team
it's a real throwback kind of thing we
wanted to do with competitive
multiplayer we want wins and losses to
matter to people we want it to feel like
when you win it feels great when you
lose you want to switch up your tactics
uh-huh I know went went wrong maybe go
back into the world and get a new
assault rifle and see if that might help
you out so that's a question with so
much investment in player customization
and you know finding that loot upgrading
your kit yeah I how do you guys keep the
balance in competitive multiplayer when
people of differing levels can bring
loadouts of differing levels to bear
yeah so what we're doing is taking away
the power advantage that level brings
when you have higher level players right
in competitive multiplayer so the level
advantage you would normally have over
AI goes away okay so somebody's at level
15 they're not gonna destroy you because
you're a level 5 it's gonna be about
your skill things are a little bit
accelerated in our alpha so a little bit
different than the final experience and
of course we're tweaking and making sure
it's going to feel good but also behind
the scenes the things that aren't
necessarily working for alpha because of
the low population is our skill based
matchmaking for all the things behind
the scenes that were actually testing
getting up to speed or use the alpha to
perfect as we go into launch but if I go
in there with my shotgun that's like him
you know I picked it up in a bargain bin
and someone has been like playing for
hours and hours in their shotgun like
glimmers with gold and looks super sexy
like they're they're not gonna far-out
classmate they're guys that go on with
their tighty whiteys in the first rifle
you get in the game just to humiliate
you of how good they are so we
absolutely want to make a skill based
environment where you've got
opportunities to tweak your build
customize your assault rifle fall in
love with a hand cannon take that into
multiplayer and really like make that
your tactic but yeah if you're if you're
really good like I watched ninja roll
through the Alpha this morning he ran
into a clan that's been playing for
about a week and he steamrolled them you
know so it's skill is important it
matters yeah absolutely and it's gotta
be paramount for that kind of
Equalization that competi
you know the foundation of this at least
this style of competitive multiplayer is
based on so I like you know you guys are
with destiny you know competitive
multiplayer when you're out in the world
you know pursuing this sort of campaign
that or other mission objectives you're
all try it you're all feeding back to
the same place you know you want it's
all interconnected yep yeah it's really
important that we have a persistence of
character in a living world that's
populated with players right so when you
go out on a campaign mission you'll see
other people you don't necessarily have
to join up you can blow right past them
but we really feel like when people see
a public event or they walk into the
rocket yard and the Sun Goes Down and
they see the hive in the fall and just
throw out their armies together and just
have this epic clash that they're gonna
want to participate in that stuff I
thought you were gonna say dance party
dance parties are good too so it's
really funny to go back to the tower we
had a community event last night we were
giving people hands-on before we open up
in the show floor and it's funny how
many people just like to spend time in
the tower and talk to their friends and
kick around a soccer ball you know that
was actually what we were doing the
other day in the game spot I was kicking
around a soccer ball yeah big guy we
were kicking it with jumped off the
cliff by happen we had a team that made
up a game old called king of the king of
the thing and they were doing like the
halo announcer where they'd go at the
end of that little parapet and they'd
try to push each other off and come you
know king of the thing new thing thing
boom pretty funny so making your own fun
I think it's pretty important in the
world of destiny
unlike a serious business campaign you
want super competitive crucible you can
have that
you just want to go out check out a
Vista go exploring maybe relax a little
bit we've got that too and Sam wood on
Twitter is wandering in crucible you
know that competitive multiplayer are
you guys just doing 6v6 modes are you
scaling up at all so this isn't the only
mode we're showcasing we're not talking
about anything outside of control 66 is
our sweet spot we want to make sure
every player is important we want to
build a Reena style maps maps that
require knowledge teamwork communication
all that fun stuff but this this is not
the end-all be-all mode this is just one
mode of core Maps that we're building
you can see here this is Rusted lands
which there aren't vehicles here at Ertz
like the other map this is all about
cat-and-mouse infantry play choosing
smart routes taking territories when
they're available when you have the
opportunity getting the high ground in
the good sight lines with the right
weapons absolutely those those
strategies that are so important have
been important to similar competitive
mode since time immemorial
yeah and continue to be so vital now
some questions coming in from Twitter
killjoy wondering about the ranking up
system you know and sort of your level
and you know competitive multiplayer
outside of the crucible outside the
crucible is the rank sort of a
persistent monolithic number that's
associated with your character you do
have a level carrot for your character
and you also have defense on your gear
and weapon proficiency all the weapons
actually gear up as well until you all
have skill trees you can unlock they
have different levels of rarity we're
actually only showing off two level
eight and the bill but the cap goes way
higher than that this is just a just
scratching the surface in terms of
weapons when you're playing the crucible
you're actually earning experience
towards all of that all of your gear
your weapons your abilities you can
tweak your movement modes your super
abilities your grenades your melee type
all of that but you're also earning
vanta
sorry you're earning a crucible
reputation that you can spend at a
crucible vendor so you actually are
going through a reputation system inside
of the crucible you've got factions
watching you for competence which also
have impact out in the world but they'll
give you better gear for performing
better here so you'll see guys when you
start seeing the in-game content in the
final game you'll start seeing people
with some really crazy looking stuff and
you'll know all you've got that inside
of the crucible and the crucible and
that's an interesting way to handle it
it's not ranked its crucible it's a
currency that you come out with a sword
or reputation system yeah
I really want people to look at another
player and know I know why you have that
special shotgun it's cuz you're really
good at the crucible but I know why you
have that epic helmet with the horns
that are glowing is because you went you
beat the raid right and those stories
are really important for us and that
sort of ties back into the thing that I
think you guys have been talking a lot
about when it comes to Bungie is that
character customization and the the look
you know the look of your hood of your
jacket of your your gauntlets you know
and of your weapons and that you know
tying that into the sense of progress
you know it's not a number but like it's
your fashion sense yeah yeah I mean we
saw a bunch of people even our friends
and family where you come down you touch
down to the tower and they're just
they're slow walking and their awesome
gear you know just to show off it's just
it's kind of a funny little strut like a
peacock mode you guys gonna build in a
cat walk into the there's a night guard
session where you go down and you find
your class mentor but there's a nice
stairs coming up in a second full boot
view as they come up it's pretty cool so
yeah it's really important for us to
have I mean we say become legend as the
marketing statement right and that's
really what it's all about is like I
want to be able to look at another
player and know what they've been
through or what kind of player they are
if I see them out in the world and
they've got gear that I haven't seen
before maybe I ask him where they got
her if I recognize the gear and I know
oh you're telling me that you like
strike so let's go take one on let's go
yeah you might be a good guy to have a
long-serving my strike mission yep all
right well I you know a competitive
multiplayer it's it's almost interesting
to sort of see it in that very sort of
basic foundational state right yeah
that's a very sort of core mode don't me
just saw control because so much of
destiny is scale is yeah we're blowing
this out you're gonna be on planets and
planets and you're gonna explore these
vast regions and so you know the mind
starts to wonder about you know the
stuff you're not talking about in terms
of competitive modes and what scale they
might take in what form they might take
I can confirm we do have other modes and
I can confirm maybe we're having a
little bit more fun than just control we
like control we want to make sure that
there's a mode for that arena style play
a really quick combat you know keep it
go in there and put their skills to the
test but there's a lot more we're not
talking about especially as you get into
the end game of destiny well I have a
question about a sort of destiny
gameplay right so people get into a
control match they know what they're in
for you know then they and if they don't
they quickly learned
because it's it's kind of the that
language of shooters and that sort of
you can trace it that pedigree
throughout that common experience yep my
question is for the the missions you're
running on earth the the stuff that's a
little bit more MMO tinge than maybe
your normal first-person shooter
campaign in which a player is used to I
show up in a place I clear all the
enemies and the enemies are gone
right but you know you guys have these
places that are that you know people are
like enemies are dropping in regularly
in there their level increases and sort
of how do you game design-wise and Kurt
like teach and encourage the player to
adopt a different mentality to just like
almost scrub this place clean and move
on to the next place yeah one of the
ways we can do that is with our director
so when you're picking activities you're
sort of making a choice of what you want
to do in the world when you go in there
for the first time you'll get a little
bit of narrative you'll get a bit a
little bit of UI to sort of set you into
place and let you know what to expect we
also want players to discover if we gets
really important for people to go what's
that thing that's beaconing over there
then making that noise and to find out
it's a treasure chest or it's a mission
from a faction or you know what if I
jump off the cliff maybe there's a cave
on the underside where there's a hive
over we want people to go out there and
try to figure out what's out there
waiting for them what does this dead
ghost do when I awaken it or what are
these grimoire points that I'm getting
we want to we want to encourage people
to go around and find out what's out
there and when they want to have a
directed experience that they're you
know I'm feeling competitive you go into
the crucible or when I want to just
relax and shoot some enemies maybe I go
take on a strike with my friends or some
match made people or if I want a really
hard strike I can ratchet up the
difficulty and make that feel really
intense and challenging so well when we
say activities for every move what we're
really saying it's like there's a lot of
stuff out there a lot of ways to play
and even in one night Mike my path
through the world is typically like land
and explore the world go get some
materials start to gear up my weapons
wait for my friends to touch down go to
the tower meet them there and then
figure out like okay what do we want to
do do we want to go take on a strike all
right let's go do that and we sort of
wind our way through the world you know
and then sort of like carve our own
little organic path through the night
and aerial it was really cool it's it's
felt that way even when we had a friends
and family which is a very limited
number of activities aha I think it's
really important for people to play
alpha and understand
and like Oh like in the center of all
this stuff is my persistent character
inside of this world of with all these
things I can do I think that's when
things start to really click so you
break it out by modes
it doesn't really sell them yeah organic
situation get in there so just find your
way III is really fun for us is you got
it all stood up and it's it's just
really exciting to see people play it
and get feedback and finally let people
off the chain people are on you know
neogaf and read it with their own videos
and twitch streams and screenshots it's
it's awesome absolutely get just gonna
take a quick few questions via Twitter
so we don't mind first one and I'm sure
that you can speak authoritative Leon
this from Jason will I be able to meet
my future fiance in destiny that sounds
like a proposal yeah I don't I mean you
know be on Venus just keep out yeah
sir-sir villa cos you're looking for
there you go so we got a little bit of
confusion on terminology from Nate
bumpass has heard sort of Titan hunter
and warlock
but where does work Vanguard fit into
that so Vanguard are the mentors in the
city they're sort of the champions of
the city you'll find them in the Hall of
Guardians so each class can go there to
get new gear new weapons and new badges
and they'll give you missions out in the
wild they're sort of monitoring all the
Guardian activity back at the tower okay
so there's your leader in that within
that given class the three classes being
you wanna world I'll give you rewards
you can go spend them at special vendors
you can earn special tokens from them
there's a whole whole bunch of currency
and reputation systems that we want to
build in they get people like bounties
or reasons to go back out in the world
again and find something new or discover
something maybe they didn't know existed
before or maybe take on a mode tweaked
or more challenging than they had they
played it before mm-hmm now when players
go out into the world they've got their
little companion peter dinkledge the the
coding ghost and that's sort of your way
of it's a it's an information source for
for learning about the lore your Jiminy
Cricket right it's sort of your
companion that's always there with you
to guide you through the world as a
character he's sort of learning
alongside you and discovering alongside
you but he there to keep you alive to
keep you safe
give you heads up because we kind of
heard his voice in the in the Trey
you guys were showing at the beginning
of the press conference the Sony press
conference and you know seems like the
ghost has knowledge has knowledge of the
world that you as a player coming in
don't have so do in a certain stent he's
a teacher but then definitely there is a
guide he's there you alive he's there to
illuminate the darkness like literally
as a flashlight held a crack but that's
not a metaphor it's not it turns on
those buildings get dark but he doesn't
have a lot of practical experience out
in the wild right so he needs the
Guardian to get him out there and keep
him alive so you guys are sort of paired
together as he's keeping you alive so
you're keeping him alive as well me and
the trailer we definitely was Peter
Dinklage we also had Bill Nye doing the
the read from the speaker at the very
beginning oh yeah we really excited
about our voice cast we've got a bunch
more announcements to make on that front
if you're playing the Alpha you're gonna
recognize some voices but we're not
confirming them for a little while but
we're having a lot of fun and we're
working with a lot of talented people
there's the dance party I was hoping for
someone who's busted a move while
capturing my seabag when you can do the
robot
I like that give us better alternatives
that's right a teabag we deserve better
yeah there's nothing worse than losing a
game and a guy sits down on your corpse
just quietly just like contemplative Lee
just cross-leg it's like it's real cozy
and comfortable it's not an athletic
exercise like no sweat off his back I
can imagine more than a few few
arguments have busted out and the Bungie
offices over over sitting etiquette
sitting Attica yeah dancing is one of
the things that we we just were having a
lot of fun with it's something that you
know some people love some people hate
but we wanted to give players ways to
express themselves without a microphone
obviously having a microphones the ideal
state and competitive multiplayer out in
the world yeah we know a lot of players
you know as they're going through their
own campaign don't want to have people
spamming their microphone and so if
they're away they can sit down or they
get in here if they do want to have an
encounter they can wave at somebody so
I'm gonna give them ways to have that
very does that stuff title through the
actual muting or not muting like you
know if I enter a like put my hands over
my ears state do I know we only open up
fire team for you it's re chat for you
in your fire team oh I'm going to the
tower you're not in today with everybody
else's chat it's an opt-in optional
experience so that's helpful
I would give you audio options and you
know all that stuff so you can tweak it
to your liking when you
to the menus white crow on Twitter says
merely and I'm not sure if this is a
haiku or not split screen split screen
ask about split screen not quite enough
syllables but so we're actually not
supporting split screen and destiny so
one of the things that we wanted to do
from the very beginning like we love
split screen obviously we've had the
legacy of supporting it we know what
players love it we love it but we really
wanted to untether Guardian so when
you're out in the world exploring you're
never gonna warp towards another player
even if you're in a fireteam you can go
wherever you want that level of freedom
was really important for us we also
wanted to make sure there weren't any
you know guests in the world we want
that character to be really important to
you and really persistent so you're
building your character getting up with
all your gear earning your weapons
earning your reputation and we didn't
want to people to sort of come in and
then come out without any sort of
exposure to that stuff so it fits into
the pillars we know that some players uh
really like split screen but they sure
do yeah but you can't have everything in
one game although you guys are kind of
trying to put really a lot in here big
game with a lot of stuff when we're
really trying to build a game that we
love but ultimately you can't build a
game to suit every single player out
there right you can't build a game
that's like you know why is it there car
racing or you know you got to be kind of
focused the good news for us is you know
with a new IP you get an opportunity to
set a foundation in place and you get to
see what players do you get to see what
the community loves about it and so then
you can start in the future thinking
about oh how do we like oh that was
really cool look what roosterteeth was
doing with Halo and go like what if we
built something to make that easy on
them and like enable that for players so
you get to be reactive and the reality
is is we have no idea what people are
gonna do and what they're gonna fall in
love with in this world we have some
ideas we think they're gonna love the
cooperative stuff sure they don't love
the competitive stuff we think people
are gonna be really surprised by the
public events and the ambient encounters
we build in the world the scope but
ultimately we're gonna be watching you
know with bated breath when this alpha
and beta goes live and at launch to see
like what are people doing what they
love do they just want to sit around the
tower and kick around a soccer ball do
we need to make like mini games there is
that what they want to tell ya maybe
they do maybe need to unwind on a
virtual holodeck of explai you know
Manchester United footing with
warlocks before we sort of reinforced
once again the alpha and beta info and
wrap the demo up I'll just give me a
give me an anecdote from your play
experience I mean you guys have been
played testing this for a long time now
you've been running through a lot of
stuff you know what what's one of the
moments that to you is sort of one of
those things it just it makes destiny
unique that makes it like what like
alright this is what we're trying to do
here yeah for me that I mean that it's
it's really two anecdotes in one but
it's the exact same experience so the
first time I ever you know we're playing
at our desk and you have this this half
assembled experience that you can take
slices up and play around but the first
time I was in a public event and I hear
shots ring out and see enemies in front
of me die and turn back and saw like my
coworker Andres Jenkins they're
reloading and the like I was like
alright this is cool hey buddy man he
landed in his ship and working now we're
gonna go off on an adventure together
uh-huh
that was awesome and I saw that in a
play test lab go down in real time our
play test labs are amazing we can watch
people play we can see if they're doing
their hands we can do eye tracking bring
them all in but I watched two guys play
together
and one guy had that exact same
experience and loading the room start
looking around for like who is that you
know playing and they had made a little
eye connection they had that little love
connection we were talking about earlier
well you know or maybe they got married
I don't know but they were just saw that
your human connection of like that's not
a I that's not a programmed NPC that's
another Guardian and I didn't expect
that it's so cool very cool well folks
are going to be able to maybe have
moments of their own come Thursday come
Thursday we're gonna open this up you
can go to greatness awaits comm slash
destiny of course the beta you can get
in by pre-ordering and that's on four
platforms PlayStation 4 PlayStation 3
Xbox one and Xbox 360 that's gonna start
on July 17th and of course all this
leads up to our launch on September 9th
and so greatness awaits calm so I just
need that's the Alpha that's the
registration for the Alpha if you want
to try to research does it work for the
beta as well or no the beta is a
pre-order is the pre-order so if you can
go to destiny the game calm slash where
to buy ok get all the URLs yeah you do
and what about this glacier white bundle
extravaganza that I know somehow right
it's awesome like enough of these black
monoliths underneath my entertainment
center that you do another selling for
me yeah yeah
my ps4 is something that they put you
know Sony put together and presented to
us and we're like this is this is
awesome this is so cool so very cool
well excited to see bungees release date
approaching fairly rapidly yeah guys
freaking out a little bit about its it's
like a meteor but you guys got you folks
at home have all the details on how to
get into the game early September times
when it's coming out Eric thank you so
much for coming on stage thanks for
having Destiny much